Sarah Michelle Geller and her daughter
who's a huge fan obviously are here
they're in the audience Sarah was crying
Amanda Klutz is in the audience what
does it feel like to have all these
wonderful people out here supporting you
I
it does it feels too it feels too like
amazing surreal you know
um yeah the the blonde Beauties over in
the corner rude you know rooting me on
rooting us on rooting all of us on it
feels good it feels so great to have
this perspective in life and Sarah's
been with me honestly from the start of
me moving to Hollywood she rooted for me
to get the part and Cruel Intentions
worked with me on it we became fast
friends forever and she was my biggest
supporter to like get me through and
feed me and do things when I was going
through a really really bad time
physically and emotionally and it's just
so amazing she she kind of cried with me
going I really didn't think you'd walk
again and so it just and you feel like
that when you can't you know but I'm
really lucky in remission and and and
really gaining strength and joy the fact
that someone said that she wouldn't know
if she would walk again but yet delivers
a dance like that is just for anyone at
home the true inspiration is right here
I agree with you wholeheartedly and I'm
inspired sitting outside I want to run
in here and high-five you when you're
done it's it's so beautiful to watch
for me
a cartwheel into a split she did please
talk to me about this moment it's
something ever since I had a stem cell
transplant that I was like okay I better
be able to do a cartwheel again because
I used to love to Tumble when I was
really little and I and I always say
like that but then I couldn't go um I
couldn't invert and like at all figure
it out I just couldn't so to be able to
do a cartwheel now and go into the
splits again
um
it really does it's like whoa I actually
changed like something actually
corrected in my brain like I can do that
and yeah it's just it's it's just a
joyous thing to get to like expand
because before proprioception I wouldn't
be able to straighten my leg I couldn't
tell where I was in space so it's all a
great feeling I love it we loved it we
loved watching it let's talk Elvis I
love the outfits everybody's wardrobe
has been amazing talk to me a little bit
the both of you about the music and the
Wardrobe it's kind of like a really fun
fantasy night of dress up in here it
totally is and we already have the Elvis
haircut like we could both get them I
mean you have the best pompadour in here
and it's real
um I loved I mean I've Loved Elvis I was
born in 72 so Elvis was like a huge part
of my young life and like everyone else
just Americana greatness and to be able
to dance to a song when I've never even
danced in my life is like let that sink
in still for all of us like we all had a
great time I love everyone here I loved
being able to do this and have a genuine
smile on my face and get to kind of
perform again it's wonderful the
theatrics at the beginning of you guys
on the bed like it adds so much richness
to a dance choreography and I know
nothing except what I naturally feel did
you guys talk about putting that
together what was that like that
creating that part of it I came up with
the pillow throw just because I fell on
the bed and I held the pillow to me like
my instincts pillow fight and I was like
actually actually we'll use that yeah
Arthur what was your favorite thing
about your mom and you can't say the
cartwheel and the split because I
already said that you got to pick
another part of the dance probably being
in jail and then Sasha like kicking the
door open
it was awesome I thought it was really
cool it was awesome we need more more of
that right we got to tell Sasha to add
that into next week's stuff oh yeah
foreign